[Music]
an illegal immigrant charged with
homicide has been released and is out on
the streets tonight because politicians
in Denver have decided that keeping our
country's borders open as a higher
priority than protecting our citizens
police say that Ivan's a Maria Castaneda
killed a truck driver in a hit and run
federal law enforcement wanted him held
in custody but thanks to Denver
sanctuary city policies authorities
there refused they did not hold him they
let him go on Friday night lawyer Paul
Ray's came on this program and said that
wasn't going to happen
the progressives in Denver were not
trying to protect illegal immigrants at
the expense of public safety watch this
why you if you're the Denver Sheriff's
Office the second policy you know this
guy's leaving at this hour be waiting
for him why wouldn't they do that what's
the answer they're not gonna get sued
for because as ice itself has said they
are issued on a daily basis weekly races
between 35 and 40 thousand of these
homicide why wouldn't they do it in this
specific case we'd ever do that well I
wouldn't think the reason they did not
was because again ice did not make him
my priority by failing to get the award
for because they did not get they don't
worry either when you left the law
enforcement they're not doing it because
they don't care that's the truth and you
know it
we was of course being disingenuous ice
asked the Denver Sheriff's Office for
notice as M Arriba Castaneda was going
to be released but deputies in Denver
refused after he posted a $25,000 bond
zemerik's Castaneda was released at
about 5:30 p.m. on Saturday evening ice
was not notified for more than an hour
and by that time he was gone Samri
Pakistan is now on the loose he's an
immigrant fugitive so a person is dead
and all the Democratic Party can think
of is how to protect his killer from
deportation that's normal on the left
now in Oakland California federal
authorities wanted to arrest drug
dealers child molesters and gang members
but Mayor Libby chef warned them so they
could get away before the feds showed up
the press howled and a woman called
Perla Morales Luna had her arrest caught
on camera you probably seen it online
today
they suggested she'd been abducted from
her family it turns out she was wanted
on human trafficking charges that may
not have made your Facebook feed unball
in Baltimore meanwhile one of the
poorest cities in the country officials
cut city funding for street lights and
trash cans to plug a hole in the budget
and yet somehow the city found hundreds
of thousands of dollars to pay lawyers
to represent illegal aliens fighting
federal law in all cases the message
could not be clearer to the rest of us
Democrats are on the side of illegal
aliens over hurting American citizens
they're not in pretending anymore